샘플 기반 양자 대각화 방법, 줄여서 SQD는 Krylov 양자 대각화 KQD처럼
VQE처럼 양자-고전 하이브리드 알고리즘이에요. 이런 하이브리드
알고리즘을 사용할 때는 각 알고리즘이 양자 컴퓨팅과 고전 컴퓨팅을 어디서 활용하는지 생각해보면 도움이 돼요. VQE는 고전적으로 최적화된 파라미터를 사용해서 quantum
circuit에서 상태를 만들어요. 그 경우 상태 자체는 양자 컴퓨터에 있는 거죠. 하지만
목표 상태를 얻는 과정은 고전 컴퓨팅과 양자 컴퓨팅을 결합해요.
연산자의 기댓값은 양자 측정을 통해 계산돼요.
하지만 고전적인 항들의 결합도 필요해요.
반면, SQD는 양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서 해밀토니안이나 다른 연산자를 투영할 수 있는 유용한 부분공간을 생성해요.
그런 다음 해밀토니안은 완전히 고전적으로 대각화해서 목표 상태를 찾아요. 우리가
과학이나 산업에서 관심 있는 문제가 있고, 그게 n행
n열 행렬의 고유값 풀이 문제로 표현된다고 해봐요. 더 나아가 n이 너무 커서 정확한 고전적 대각화가 불가능하다고 해요.
기저 상태의 모든 관련 특성을 보존하면서 행렬의 차원을 줄이면 명확히 유리하겠죠. 실제로 그게 바로
고전적 Krylov 방법을 포함한 많은 근사 고유값 풀이 방법의 목표예요. 우리 문제에 대해 기저 상태의 형태를
그럭저럭 잘 추측할 수 있지만 문제를 완전히 풀기엔 충분하지 않다고 가정해봐요. 그럴 때
목표 기저 상태의 합리적인 근사를 여러 번 측정할 수 있어요. 그 측정 결과들로
우리 기저 상태의 모든 관련 성분을 포함하는 계산 기저 상태들의 부분공간을 얻을 수 있어요.
그 부분공간에 투영하면 관련 자유도를 여전히 포함하는 더 작은 행렬을 얻을 수 있어요.
이 과정의 워크플로우는 다음과 같아요. 먼저 좋은
ansatz를 선택해요. 더 정확하게는, 목표 상태의 support와 일치하는 support를 가진 ansatz를 선택하세요. 정확히 무슨 뜻인지
곧 설명할게요. 다음으로, sampler primitive처럼 계산 기저에서 상태를 측정해요.
그런 다음, 샘플링 결과를 사용해서 기저 상태를 포함하는 부분공간을 정의해요.
그런 다음, 그 부분공간에 행렬을 투영해요. 마지막으로, 더 작은 투영 행렬을 고전적으로 대각화해요.
각 단계를 하나씩 살펴봐요. 특히 부분공간 정의에 주목할게요.
양자 컴퓨팅 전반에서 좋은 ansatz를 선택하는 건 항상 중요해요. SQD의 경우, ansatz 선택에 따라
샘플링에서 측정될 수 있는 계산 기저 상태가 결정돼요.
실제 기저 상태는 계산 기저 상태들의 일부 부분집합의 중첩으로 표현될 수 있어요. 그 부분집합을
기저 상태의 support라고 해요. 기저 상태와 그 에너지를 잘 추정하려면, ansatz가
기저 상태의 support에 있는 계산 기저 상태에 0이 아닌 투영을 가져야 해요.
이 다이어그램은 사용 중인 qubit 수에서 가능한 모든 상태로 이루어진 공간을 나타내요. 우리는
실제 기저 상태의 support를 포함하는 support를 가진 ansatz를 원해요.
기저 상태가 다음과 같은 아주 작은 예시를 생각해봐요. 기저 상태는 8 *
상태 1 0 0 + 6 * 상태 0 0 1이에요.
이건 두 벡터 1 0 0과 0 0 1로 이루어진 support를 가져요. ansatz가 형태가 ANSATZ 1이 A times
상태 1 0 0 + B * 상태 0 1 0 + C * 상태 0 0 1이라고 해봐요. 그러면
support는 세 벡터 1 0 0, 0 1 0, 0 0 1의 집합으로, 기저 상태 support의
상위집합이에요. 이건 좋은 ansatz예요.
이번엔 형태가 ANSATZ 2가 a * 인
상태 1 1 0 + b * 상태 0 1 1인 ansatz를 선택했다고 해봐요.
이건 두 벡터 1 1 0과 0 1 1로 이루어진 support를 가지는데, 기저 상태의 support와 겹치지 않아요.
이건 나쁜 ansatz예요.
ansatz가 반드시 기저 상태의 좋은 근사일 필요는 없어요. ansatz는
훨씬 더 큰 support를 가지거나 계수가 ansatz와 실제 기저 상태에서 매우 달라도 잘 작동할 수 있어요.
이 단계에서 우리는 잘 동기화된 방법으로 양자 컴퓨터가 목표 상태와 유사한 상태를 채택하게 했어요.
여기 보이는 건 unitary coupled cluster 또는 UCJ ansatz인데, 양자 화학에서 매우 유용해요.
이제 각 qubit의 붕괴 상태를 설명하는 비트 문자열을 얻어서 시스템 상태를 측정하고 싶어요.
VQE에서처럼 해밀토니안 추정에는 많은 양자 측정이 필요해요. 이건 부분적으로
불확실성을 줄이기 위해서이기도 하고, 해밀토니안을 구성하는 교환 Pauli 그룹의 수 때문이기도 해요.
샘플링 방법에서도 많은 측정이 필요하지만 이유가 달라요. 이제는 고도로 얽힌 양자 상태에 포함된
많은 계산 기저 상태를 효과적으로 샘플링하기 위해 많은 측정이 필요해요. SQD에서 샘플링된 비트 문자열은
시뮬레이션된 시스템의 구성에 해당해요. 연구 중인 시스템이 물리학이나 화학의
보존 법칙 같은 절대적 제약을 받는다면 측정된 상태의 대부분은 유효할 거예요. 하지만 일부 샘플링된
비트 문자열은 노이즈와 오류로 인해 유효하지 않거나 비물리적인 구성에 해당해요. 구성 복구라는 과정은
이런 노이즈가 있는 샘플들을 더 정확한 구성 집합으로 정제하는 걸 목표로 해요.
이 과정은 평균 궤도 점유율과 알려진 입자 수를 기반으로 개별 비트를 확률적으로 뒤집어서
새로운 구성을 생성하는 걸 포함해요.
정제된 구성들은 해밀토니안 투영과 대각화를 위한 부분공간을 이루는 데 사용되고,
양자 상태 표현의 정확도를 반복적으로 개선해요.
구성 복구의 의미를 이해하기 위해 아주 간단한 예시를 살펴봐요. 4개의 분자 궤도를 나타내는
4개의 qubit을 가진 양자 시스템을 측정하고, 양자 프로세서에서 다음 비트 문자열들을 얻는다고 해봐요.
각 비트 문자열은 궤도의 점유율을 나타내요. 점유는 1,
비점유는 0이에요. Qiskit은 최하위 유효 qubit이 맨 오른쪽에 오는 표기법을 사용해요.
예를 들어, 1 0 1 0은 궤도 1번과 3번이 점유됨을 나타내요. 이
측정값들은 교육적 목적으로만 선택된 거예요. 결과 점유율은 물리 시스템과 맞지 않을 수 있어요. 물리적 맥락에서는
시스템의 총 입자 수가 알려져 있는 경우가 많아요. 측정된 상태의 물리성을 판단하기 위해 활용할 수 있는
다른 보존 법칙들도 있을 수 있어요. 구체적으로, 우리 시스템의
총 입자 수가 n=2로 알려져 있다고 해봐요. 이건 상태 레이블에 나타나야 할 1의 총 개수를 알려주는데,
이걸 해밍 가중치 제약이라고 해요.
하지만 일부 측정된 구성은 이 제약을 위반해요. 상태 1 0 1 0은 물리적으로 유효해요. 하지만 상태 1 1
1 0은 입자가 너무 많고, 모두 0인 상태는 입자가 너무 적어요. 0개죠.
이런 위반은 시스템의 노이즈나 측정 오류 때문일 수 있어요. 최소한 근사적으로라도
물리적으로 의미 있는 구성으로 되돌아갈 방법이 필요해요.
이걸 구성 복구라고 해요.
노이즈가 있는 샘플을 수정하기 위해, 유효한 구성들의 평균 궤도 점유율을 기반으로
유효하지 않은 구성의 비트를 확률적으로 뒤집어요.
궤도 점유율은 각 궤도에 작용하는 수 연산자의 기댓값이에요. 이건 SQD에서 생성된 상태를 사용해서
자기 일관성 있게 추정하고 정제해요. 예를 들어 궤도 2번을 살펴봐요. 네 개의
유효한 구성 중 두 개에서 궤도 2번이 점유됐어요. 이건 기대 점유율 0.5를 줘요.
나머지 세 궤도에도 같은 작업을 해요. 이제 유효하지 않은 구성 1 1 0으로 돌아가요. 비트 하나를
1에서 0으로 뒤집어서 유효한 구성을 만들 수 있어요. 그런데 어떤 걸 뒤집어야 할까요? 결정하는 한 가지 방법은
방금 계산한 평균에서 각 궤도 점유율의 편차를 보는 거예요.
여기서 가장 큰 차이는 궤도 1번의 점유에서 나타나요. 그래서 비트 1번이
1에서 0으로 뒤집혀야 할 것 같아요. 물론 궤도 2번도 많이 다르지 않아요. 아무리 가능성이 낮더라도,
측정된 상태가 같은 상태에서 여러 오류가 발생한 결과일 수도 있어요.
모든 유효하지 않은 상태에서 평균으로부터 가장 큰 편차만 선택하는 건 최적이 아니에요. 대신, 여기 보이는
차이의 함수인 확률로 비트를 확률적으로 뒤집어요. 이 경우 평균 점유율에서
가장 많이 다른 비트를 변경한다고 가정해봐요. 그러면 1 1 0이 0 1 0이 돼요. 나머지
유효하지 않은 선택에도 같은 과정을 적용해요. 이 경우 비트 1번과 3번을 뒤집는다고 해봐요.
이 수정 과정 후, 새로운 구성 집합이 이렇게 될 수 있어요.
이 정제된 집합을 사용해서 정확도를 높이기 위해 평균 궤도 점유율을 업데이트할 수 있어요. 우리 경우 새
점유율은 이렇게 돼요.
이 반복적인 복구 과정은 노이즈가 있는 측정이 물리적으로 의미 있는
구성으로 걸러지도록 해서 SQD에서 고유 상태 근사의 정확도를 높여요. SQD Qiskit 애드온에는
이 과정에서 도움이 될 도구들이 있어요. 시스템의 실제 기저 상태 support에 있는 상태들을 잘 샘플링했다면,
이 부분공간에서 작용하는 해밀토니안 부분만 살펴봐도
좋은 기저 상태와 에너지를 얻을 수 있어요. 아주 간단한 4 qubit 예시에서는 처음에 2의 4제곱, 즉 16개의
가능한 시스템 상태가 있어요. 샘플링과 구성 복구를 결합해서
관심 있는 부분공간의 3개 상태로 줄여요. 실제 기저 상태의 support를 구성하길 기대하는 3개의 상태로요.
이제 전체 해밀토니안을 그 부분공간에 투영해요. 즉, 복구된 샘플링 부분공간의 벡터 열로 행렬 M을 만들고,
행으로 유사한 M dagger를 만들어서 M dagger HM을
시각적으로 곱해요. 이건 복구된 샘플링 부분공간의 상태에 해당하는 행과 열의 행렬 원소를 가져온다는 의미예요.
강조된 행과 열이 우리 부분공간에 해당하는 것들이에요. 그리고
겹치는 부분의 더 어둡게 강조된 상자들이 새로운 투영 행렬에 유지할 원소들이에요.
이제 관심 있는 부분공간을 선택했으니, 고전 컴퓨터에서
표준 솔버를 사용해서 이 행렬을 대각화할 수 있어요. 실제 기저 상태가 완전히 우리 부분공간의 상태들로 이루어져 있다면,
이 대각화로 정확한 기저 상태와 기저 상태 에너지를 얻어야 해요. 기저 상태 support의 대부분만 가지고 있다면
근사치를 얻을 수 있어요. 투영된 해밀토니안의 기저 상태를 얻으면, 각 궤도의 평균 점유율을
계산하기 위한 매우 유용한 상태를 가지게 돼요.
이전에는 기저 상태에 접근하는 데 도움이 되길 바라며 선택한 ansatz를 사용해서 샘플링한 상태들로 점유율을 계산했어요.
하지만 그 샘플링의 각 궤도 평균 점유율이 최저 에너지 상태의 점유율과 일치한다는 보장이 없었어요.
다시 정리해볼게요. 계산 상태들을 샘플링했어요. 구성 복구를 사용해서 물리적으로 유효하지 않은 것들을 수정했어요.
그런 다음 모든 상태를 사용해서 평균 궤도 점유율을 계산했어요.
기저 상태는 그 중 일부만 포함할 수도 있어요. 투영된 해밀토니안의 기저 상태는 원래 시스템의 실제 기저 상태가 아닐 수 있지만,
복구된 상태들의 어떤 중첩으로도 만들 수 있는
우리 부분공간에서 가장 낮은 에너지 상태예요. 이 상태의 궤도 점유율은 복구된 공간의 점유율에서 얻은 에너지보다
작거나 같은 에너지를 낼 거예요. 그래서 이 점유율은 우리 기저 상태 점유율의 더 나은 추정치예요.
이 새 점유율을 사용해서 구성 복구 과정을 반복할 수 있고, 수렴 기준을 충족할 때까지
이걸 반복할 수 있어요. 샘플 기반 양자 대각화는 VQE 같은
다른 근거리 알고리즘보다 빠르고, 확장성이 더 좋으며, 샘플링의 노이즈와 오류에 강해요.
하지만 여전히 시스템의 실제 기저 상태 support에 대한 큰 투영을 가진 좋은 ansatz를 준비해야 해요. 실제 기저 상태에 대해 전혀 알려진 바가 없다면,
SQD는 기저 상태에 대해 먼저 파악하고 반복적으로 접근하기 위해 다른 방법들과 함께 사용해야 할 수 있어요.
기저 상태에 반복적으로 접근하면서요.
SQD는 떠오르는 고전-양자 하이브리드 알고리즘 스위트에서 중요한 역할을 하며,
유용한 양자 컴퓨팅을 향한 가장 큰 원동력 중 하나예요.